top story tonight a metro canine unit
crashes into a robbery suspect who led
police on a chase for miles both the k-9
and handler expected to be okay but
we're taking a u-m-c along with the
suspect sasha loftus is live now where
that chase ended sasha with more on what
exactly unfolded
brian still quite the scene here along
decatur right near charleston if you
take a look behind me here police say
this is the suspect's car that was
involved in this crash this person
reportedly crashed with that k-9 unit as
you mentioned here on decatur after that
officer-involved shooting that turned
into a chase up in the northeast valley
metro police say this began as a robbery
near pecos and cheyenne that turned into
a police shooting that's when the chase
started i-team sources tell eight news
now and left multiple crime scenes
across the valley they say it all ended
here at charleston in decatur when the
suspect and a metro canine unit crashed
police tell us the officer inside was
taken to umc as you also mentioned both
he and the dog are okay now the suspect
was also taken to the hospital and
arrested i-team sources also tell us at
least one other person was hurt by
gunfire throughout this entire ordeal
back out here live as for road closures
you can see this part of decatur between
charleston and okie is shut down there
are also several other road closures
across the valley we have more on those
on our website this is still a
developing story we're expecting a
briefing from police coming up in just a
few minutes so stay with 8 news now
throughout the night and in the morning
starting at 4 a.m reporting live tonight
sasha loftis 8 news now